Frances even more impressive right
because he's natural I mean he's not
even barely lifting weights I mean that
guy's just a [ __ ] crazy eye Gant
except or ass so that guy doesn't really
left no he got that big from working in
a [ __ ] sand mine oh my god this is I
mean he literally is like Conan the
Barbarian from the Robert E Howard
insane Nigerian he is from Cameroon I
believe right I think that's where he's
gonna come he there's videos of him on
his Instagram from yesterday of him back
in the same sand mine and he's wearing
his [ __ ] Reebok Jersey with his name
on the back of it digging sand with all
the guys he used to work with yeah it's
[ __ ] crazy but that is hard labour
and it's good there is do that all day
dig [ __ ] stand all day you know
[ __ ] strong you had been just
carrying 20-pound hunks of sand and
shoving them onto the top of that truck
I'm so efficient he's a beast well he's
he's got tremendous genetics his father
is built like him too there's a picture
of him on his Instagram when he was
three years old standing next to his
father and you look at his daddy like oh
Jesus like the Apple in the tree they
are baby you think he's gonna be pretty
dangerous coming up like the only issue
with Francis is his wrestling and isn't
in his endurance and this is just based
on his fight with stipa Miocic who in my
opinion is the best heavyweight ever yes
right if you look at what's t-pain's
managed to do in his career he's
defending the title more than anybody he
knocked out four breezy over dune was
one of the best ever he knocked out
Alistair Overeem he beat Francis and
Ghana who everybody is [ __ ] terrified
of and France has been blowing everybody
out of the water including Alistair
Overeem I just think and knocked out
Junior dos Santos also former
heavyweight champion I think Steve pays
the best of all time so when you know
steep a is able to beat you and beat you
by using his wrestling and using his
smarts and using his his octagon
intelligence and just his overall fight
IQ he just knows how to fight better he
just got more tools in the toolbox
Francis can learn and he's an incredible
athlete and what he has over everybody
is power he has more power in his punch
we have a machine out there called the
power cube
that machine Frances registered the
highest-ever power punch by like 10,000
units whatever the [ __ ] that means
so Tyrone Spong who's a super powerful
heavyweight boxer he scored like 119 I
think it was and for 114 and then
Frances scored 129 129,000 and you see
it when he hits people and that's about
what you kick right
you should check a little bit more than
that so that's a game I kicked in the
face I hold the record right now until
somebody pays you go well hold the red
152 152 from a kick that's but again
look at the size of my level carrying
around 196 pounds all day running Hills
with 196 pounds try try doing [ __ ]
handstands and running up a hill with
handstands you just can't your arms are
not that strong and also you know I've
been kicking my whole life he's really
only been training MMA for five years
yeah so he's just fun to watch
he's amazing to watch it's like an old
Tyson fight yeah even the match even the
fight with us TPA was kind of scary
because he just kept getting back up it
was like it was like watching Mike Myers
like a horror movie or something Michael
Myers and Freddy Krueger's or something
just kept coming back doesn't have the
wrestling experience it doesn't have the
wrestling technique but woody has is
incredible heart and desire and he's
very hungry to learn and I'm very
hopeful that he's going to learn and you
know and I really really hope that he
incorporates a real rigorous wrestling
program because that was one thing that
was lacking from his last lose last
training camp when he fought for steep
and I think UFC needs a 300 up club I
think so you know to have that have that
weight class and then have them only
fight for a minute and rest for like
five minutes
well there's nothing shoes is not enough
fighters yeah there's not enough guys
you know but not enough big boys yeah
maybe you just like put you saw it on
the back burner for you know you know
I'm hopeful that Francis still I mean
he's a little older in terms of like
being this new to the sport at 33 you
know I mean really didn't even start
training until he was 28 I mean he's
kind of crazy was homeless yeah I mean
you want to talk about our amazing story
that's like right out of a movie the guy
was homeless came from Africa where he
worked in a [ __ ] sand mine and then
gets to the number one contender spot in
the UFC but there's guys now like
Alexander Volkov is that is Volcom
Volkov Volkov the guy who'd just knocked
out febri she over doom he's this this
is a giant guy like he's a huge
I think he's six seven G's yeah an
incredibly skillful so there's there's
these guys that are coming up that are
like at the higher end of the weight
class his last name
Volkov right I always get confused cuz
Russians say things with Russian accent
I was under the volkl Volkov Volkov it
is yeah he find out that's the case if
he is that tall he's six seven yeah he's
incredibly long and efficient and he has
real power he and he's hard to hit man
but his game is so well-rounded the
difference between him and a guy like
you know Francis is he's not new to the
game I mean he's a giant guy who's been
fighting for a long [ __ ] time so he
is a real efficient martial artist when
he fought Fabricio Werdum I could tell
early on these striking exchanges like
wow Fabrizio might be in trouble like
this guy is he's long he knows how to
stay on the outside and he knows he's
got an excellent sense of distance and
he's got legit knockout power he [ __ ]
for bricio up man that was that was hard
to watch I was like wow this guy's he's
legit to me